black boxes which are usually thought of
as in airplanes that's where they get
all the data after there's a crash or
something right now they're actually in
ninety percent of all new vehicles sold
in the United States which is a crazy
amount and by 2014 if the National
Highway Traffic Safety Administration
has its way it'll be in all new cars
sold in America and I think this is
interesting because it goes to all this
privacy stuff that we've been talking
about you know the government's watching
your metadata on your emails and on your
phone calls and then in just in terms of
with the car you know if you have EZ
Pass or one of those things they know
when you're what bridge you're going
over and when you're doing it and now
they're going to have the black box
which is going to tell them how fast
you're going and you know if you went
through a red light and all that stuff
does this ever end I mean this again is
the technology thing but does this stuff
ever really end in any sort of good way
for for regular people I would think it
it was it's okay to a point but the
problem is as soon as the insurance
companies came in and said they'd like
to know about how this is working
yeah and we're gonna stir your safety I
don't trust any insurance company don't
you I
I'm a digital store really quickly my
car was scratch in a parking lot when
you leave your keys with the attendant
it was a lot of people's at work is our
last few Lots ago and I asked my said
did you scratch you girls don't even
know when that happened so I said
someone must've scratched by it so I go
through their insurance company for the
lot I was like well you know you own a
lot is there some way through this their
first response I mean before they even
assess the information was whoa notes
please why would be our fault has none
do this yeah when it's in your leg I
mean John you're Gia yeah but I would I
would enjoy if you at least act like you
looked at the situation yes you know
pretend like you're doing your job yeah
so the I don't trust them I'm worried
with my little black box by the way
you're saying because the black box will
record the scratch and then you'll be
able to the reasons because I know that
guy who's thinking but what do they do
to fiddle with this black box there's
technology behind the black box right
and can I trust what information they've
collected from this black box because
the nurse a junior you 100 miles an hour
like I swear I was going 65 right so
they'll be able to tag you for speeding
all the time again know what bridges
you're going over and how fast your
and you're using Google Maps already to
get wherever you're going so know where
you're going I want to play everything
into this paranoid yes state but it's
all sort of legit and we kind of need to
talk about it right it is and it once
again it's the slippery slope with this
stuff it's like oh well it's in there
how do we go back how do we draw a line
with this I mean this is a device in my
car that I own I own that device and
you're telling me I have no control over
the information in spite of it what's up
cuz go right there right because if you
want a car if they get their way every a
choice to turn it off
can a my allowed to do that can I opt
out wouldn't that maybe that would be a
nice little thing maybe we could lobby
for an opting out because we should be
able to do that take three thousand
dollars off the price of my car if you
don't have been in there okay if I get
come if you get come to control of it
here you pay the extra three thousand
eight I think we have an image of the
black box by the way let's take a look
and see what a black box looks like it's
not even black all that it's just a
little metal box you run across it you
have no idea oh and you know here's the
thing too is that okay if I mean almost
every single I've been an accident a
long time yeah knock on wood but the two
that I was in that were bad the other
person lied through their teeth so in
some ways it's like if this thing does
have true information and we were all to
use it in a really you know justified
way it could be it could be a good thing
of course but that's just like the NSA
stops right there right I mean and if
ever that's the thing and then that's
the problem with all the spying and all
this stuff the ifs are what we're all
afraid of and those are the things that
end up and that's what our Constitution
generally in the past used to protect us
against all of those gray area ifs you
know benefit of the doubt kind of things
and that is that's all going away
there's no more benefit of the doubt for
any of us you know we're all in service
of this other thing and you know I'm
just thinking the other day just even
the term big data which is what they use
it's such a 1984 doublespeak thing it
doesn't mean anything it sounds cool iBM
has commercials about it it's got
graphics yeah it's got its own PR agency
obviously
but it's if you know if I was seeing to
interview with Edward Snowden this
morning and it was like hearing him talk
and it was like wow when you get down to
what these people are really really
doing big data is just such a
whitewashing of what's going on it's
just yeah all right so we'll go with a
little jump off that then how much of
this is just they let us know about this
kind of stuff you know we find out about
the NSA stuff we find about black boxes
in our cars and phone tapping analyze up
how much of it is actually not even the
literal stuff that they're doing but the
real value in it is just the fear that's
created around it you know you mean at
this point it makes no difference
whether they catch Snowden or whatever
but there's now a sense of fear you know
people have already said that the
informants are being quieter now people
are losing contact so it's really about
fear more than the specific little
instances right I mean of course if they
get the chance to get Edward stone they
don't get them yeah but in the meantime
they're thinking well at least it's not
gonna be any others because do you want
to go through this right you want to sit
in the nothing like a Transit Center in
Russia and we know how great Russia is
right he's definitely not wearing
anything with the rain warnings that one
that law to be considered ready for
lunch
how sick of Panda Express he must be
like Woody is he just have to go to the
food court every day like where is he
really no one's talking about it doesn't
anyone have Google glass at the Russian
air Moorea borscht buffet this guy's
thinking yeah